US national debt held by the public
is at almost $22 trillion or about $67,000
per citizen surpassing
the country's annual GDP
for the first time, since World War II.
The congressional budget office
predicts that it'll reach
102% of GDP by the end of 2021
and hit 202% by 2051.
The federal government's growing
debt burden would increase
the risk of a fiscal crisis
and higher inflation as well as
undermine confidence in the US dollar.
CBO concluded in it's March,
2021 long-term budget outlook.
If the world were to lose
confidence in the dollar,
what could replace it?
Another fiat currency, gold, Bitcoin?
That was the topic of a recent
Oxford style debate hosted by
the Soho Forum.
John Vallis, a financial consultant
and host of the Bitcoin Rapid Fire podcast
believes that Bitcoin
will eventually replace
government's fiat money as the
preferred medium of exchange.
He argues that Bitcoin's global adoption
is a matter of when, not if.
Lawrence H. White an
economics professor at
George Mason University is skeptical
of Bitcoin's future as money.
He believes that may have a
future as a financial asset,
but isn't suitable to become
a global medium of exchange.
The debate was moderated
by Soho Forum, director,
Gene Epstein, and held
before a live audience
at the Porcupine Freedom Festival,
better known as PorcFest in
Lancaster, New Hampshire.
Here is the Soho Forum debate
on the future of Bitcoin
as the world's medium of exchange.
The resolution reads 'Bitcoin
will eventually replace
government's fiat money
as the preferred medium of exchange.'
Please vote, we'd like to
have a substantial vote
again you see it's yes, no, or undecided.
And the program that was
specially written for us,
will make sure that your vote counts
only if you vote both times.
And we can actually
trace the flow of voting
through the program app.
So it was kind of a
fascinating exercise to do so,
but again, that's the resolution,
please vote yes, no or undecided.
And to defend the resolution,
we have John Vallis,
who does the podcast, Bitcoin Fire.
John Vallis, please come to the stage.
Taking the negative on the resolution,
we have George Mason University
professor Larry White.
Larry, please come to the stage.
Jane, please close the voting, all closed.
Thank you, Jane, and
John, you have 15 minutes
to defend the resolution,
take it away, John.
Well, first of all,
it's great to be here because
I'm actually a refugee.
I may not look like it,
but I recently escaped
the Canadian gulags,
and now I'm here
(audience cheers)
in the land of the free,
and if my voice is a
little hoarse forgive me,
I was in Miami for the Bitcoin
conference, and since then,
I've been having a ton of
conversations with Bitcoiners down
in Miami, and it's been amazing.
So if I'm coughing a
little bit, I apologize.
Also, I drove up from Boston
yesterday and I noticed on the
welcome to New Hampshire sign,
it said, live free or die.
And you got to imagine as a Canadian,
I'm not used to that kind of shit, right?
We're more used to like do
whatever the government tells you
to do and everything will be fine.
So I thought that was
pretty fucking awesome
to see that as a slogan.
We have to keep this narrow
because this is the proposition
of Bitcoin will inevitably
replace government fiat as a
preferred medium of exchange.
Bitcoin is a very deep rabbit hole,
there's lots of stuff to discuss about it.
So I'm gonna have to
necessarily keep a lot of this
fairly brief and I'll focus on
the resolution specifically.
I'm not gonna be talking
about Austrian economics today
or quoting dead Austrians
or any kinds of economic
economists actually.
And that's because I don't
think it's necessary.
Bitcoin is money and money is something
we interact with on a daily basis
and so I think money is
a very intuitive thing.
It's just not something that people
have had the opportunity to
actually think about because
we've never really had a choice.
You use the government fiat or else,
but now we do have a
choice, and what this is
fostering is a tremendous
explosion of people that are for
the first time, thinking about money
and asking these questions about what
makes a good money and
what money should be
and what money shouldn't be.
And so what I have done
for my own Bitcoin journey
is to do that, to think
about this critically.